hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde peyton spielt heute zum
ersten mal mario kart hast du schon mal
so richtig mal glück hat spielte
nintendo ds gespielt er ist quasi genau
das gleiche hat die straße komplett
zufällig ausgewählt worden du weißt du
noch wie die steuerung so grob
funktioniert vom ds
[Applaus]
ich würde sagen dass ich jetzt das
rennen komplett uncut drin lassen weil
ich warum ehrlich gesagt ich habe
einfach abschneiden wie sie sind es
nicht viel zu sagen warum wir wollen
super mit maultaschen
aber real zu
lassen
sowas muss natürlich auch schnell ich
finde es auch ehrlich gesagt bei anderen
youtuber nimmer so ein bisschen stressig
wenn bei mario kart geschnitten wird ich
habe noch nie mario kart video sehen
nicht meins von damals
eine video
[Musik]
ja die sache ist halt ein paar anderen
youtube angesehen vor allem halt im
ausland und immer bei den ganzen japaner
die ganze rekorde aufstellt und da finde
ich es so schlimm wenn die dann
irgendwie auch fanny daneben wie
schneiden oder anwendungen machen und
das passt nicht weil ich bin soweit hin
ich hatte auch die ganze box genommen
ich will das jetzt bist du ich bin
vierter ich will auch an ihm
vorbeigefahren
schalter ich war auch mal besser in
diesem spiel
die sache ist was ich sagen wollte ich
finde immer stress für leute bei marica
schneien weil man will ja sehen wie wann
was passiert ist
das war richtig stark gerade von mir
ich gucke nicht aufs spiel große rakete
du bist nur zwei plätze hinter mir sagt
sie wenn du das bottich den rakete
hinter mir
wenn du das vor mir nicht davor das
spiel auch schwierigkeit schwierig ist
ja wie es richtig gut gerade also ihr
werdet jetzt von uns gleich vier rennen
hier sehen also ihr seht ja gerade schon
das erste rennen jetzt die letzte runde
und danach noch drei andere und alles
dann erkannt während der rennen außer
dass ich so sachen eine scheiße sagt
dass der aussteller und jetzt bei mir
auch ausgestellt welche auch scheiße und
das monster wider rausschneiden weil ich
hab's wieder gesagt
die kann wenn leute neben der herr
fahren ist er die auf erster den
sekunden später kommt
der berater mir vorbeigeflogen warum
nicht in der luft nein wo setze mich
okay zum überfordert bitte sag bitte
nicht solchen fall sagen
ich konnte erst wenn ich trainer werden
was heißt denn sagen ich bin erster
schön für dich
ich bei dir hinter ich
gut so stark dass zusätzlich
findet ihr übrigens die ansicht die
leute ich hab mir das überlegt bei der
kern das eigentlich gleich ganz ehrlich
das gepäck bis 12
auch mano vielleicht wird zum nächsten
rennen besser
[Musik]
das ist halt eine richtige richtige
abspecken
wir fahren halt die ganze zeit durchs
weltall und es gibt keine banden
ich bin runter gefallen
[Musik]
das ist so nicht
sagen
manometer
ich war ja immer meinen stiefel vorne
ich war meinen stiefel aber das macht
man so
12 trennen ja
die geht es im übrigen der verlierer
muss wodka zu trinken
dieser gefahr
nicht so gut aber das gut weil es mit
der blaue geht auf dem anderen nein und
ich fahre noch durch ich
mich wieder runter gefallen
das ist so da bist du fünfter
aber ich bin so dumm runtergefallen
gerade oh ich habe stern ich habe stehe
auf dem platz
[Musik]
fast ein triple double
keine ahnung ich weiß auch nicht ob
ich ihn habe ich in die kurve und zwar
nicht stark das war richtig stark dass
auch richtig sagt das ist so stark wenn
ich wieder der erste platz ist kriege
auf den letzten metern dass er so habe
man hasst ihn schon wieder eine rakete
zu ändern ich denke wenn es so
und ich dachte schon das ziel um
lokalisierten sie einfach da mal okay
aber ich bin zweiter
ich
bin noch nicht
[Musik]
ganz
da nur mit boost rüber
[Musik]
drittes rennen hätten los geht's aber
los geht wird auf los geht's los richtig
sagt und jetzt was das was sagst du
finden so kann mir sagen jetzt vorher
was wir denken wie viel platz wie werden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie welcher welcher idiot hat mich ihr
angeschossen ich idiot sagen war doch in
die ok aber ich will nicht dass schon
wieder dass sich ein streik gucken
gestern das video hochgeladen dass ich
ein strike auf dem zwei kanal bekommen
habe danke für eure ganzen lieben
kommentare ich habe das auch noch mal
unter das video geschrieben das video
war natürlich nicht dazu da um das ich
jetzt irgendwie mit leid krieg oder
keine ahnung was das war einfach nicht
anders möglich darüber also die youtube
zuschauer wer auf youtube habe ich viel
andere leute die mit zuschauern als
beispielsweise auf insider ja es geht
einfach nur darum dass ich euch
informieren wollte das auf dem 2 keine
videos kommen weil ich halte diesen
streit bekommen habe aufgrund
erklärlichen gründen ich bin einfach
jemand der kinder attackiert mit blick
auf jeden fall will ich dass wir auch
noch mal sicher sicher sicher sicher
gehen wird hierauf nicht reagieren wenn
eh nichts machen laden einfach ein
schönes mario kart wii hoch ich dachte
jetzt darum geht wenn jemand
babyschwimmen und baby paket von einem
panzer das dann inhalt
schutzpakete so hast du immer raketen
bei marica ist dass ich scheiße wenn ich
mir auch mal schon hast schon wieder das
wort gesagt
man jetzt will ich gegen die wand
gefahren wegen dir nanometer 1 nanometer
40 dürfen
sagt schon nein
jetzt habe ich das auch noch
ich war ein richtig gutes rennen hier
gerade komme jetzt drei rädern ich kann
nichts mehr aufhalten ich bin siebter
neunter
ich kann nichts mehr aufhalten ausland
lauern
warum intel geht so wenn du ein stern
hat das heißt ganz europa voran japan
übersandt uhr wirst nicht langsamer du
wirst von uns aufgehalten
da kommt blauer schaffte es vorher ins
ziel staub nicht
aber ich war richtig gut gerade peyton
ich mir dann wage erster wird gut wird
wird dass sie wahr werden das ist schön
für dich nervt mich dass jetzt lass mich
mal denn du hast eine hinter mir nicht
ob nicht wenn du nein ich wurde geholt
wie kann das denn sein ich war die ganze
zeit mein rennen machen nichts falsch
und werde überholt so wie immer
ich bin noch nicht letzter das ist gut
für mich ich bin erster ich hab's
geschafft
ich hab's geschafft
wenn du sie als elfter zu werden haben
wir uns
warum münchen darunter gefühlen oder
wie wärs luc
loos mit links wenn du wirklich auch
elfter wir
jetzt öffentlich gemacht
letztes rennen baby park das ist nur im
kreis fahren peyton richtig geil ich
hätte gedacht dass so richtig es so
richtig coole das richtig doofe strecken
jetzt kommt vor allem welche von den
neuen weil es kam mir so ein dlc raus
was heißt sie hätten downloadable
content richtig da kann man sich jetzt
neue strecken runterladen und so ich
habe das auch gemacht aber ich finde die
neuen strecken ist ja nicht so geil sind
alle unter euch hingegen du das gemacht
bitte mit nelly letzten sie hier war das
haben
ja das heißt auch schon allerdings
gesehen die strecken gesehen konnte
durch paris fahren uns war es alles und
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich finde das nicht
so gut die neuen strecken ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich bin ja auch groß geworden
und hat deswegen bin ich vielleicht erst
strecken baby park oder vario abfahrt
oder
darüber reden und wir fahren auch nur im
kreis also wenn du hier letzter wäre
dass dann
das war wirklich traurig ich hab ne
rakete ja was ganz neues die sache ist
nur dass im inland nur recht gute
strecken was ich bin
du bist du dritter
jetzt will ich fünfter scheiße nicht
dass schuld daran ist auch nichts
gemacht da unten gelenkt 9 bei baby hast
du kein einziges mal aus dem dings
kompensieren wollen schon wieder ist die
vorletzte runde
kommen letzte runde bitte gib mir die
ersten platz vier am ende ist irgendwie
die aufnahme abgestürzt von der switch
deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt hier
einfach so die ergebnisse
hätten
haushoch verloren und an der stelle wenn
wir das heutige jetzt auch beenden in
euch mario kart mit table soccer
gefeiert das ganze ein daumen hoch unter
dem tier da haben ihm ein kanal und
klickt auf die glocken beispiel videos
nicht verpassen wir sehen uns immer
anders wieder